maybe like wu-tang probably hi what's up
we are almost at the end I think this is
the finale I'm excited I want it to be
um sorry took us long to get here no
making excuses every episode but well
really it's an excuse it's a pretty good
excuse like I want to do this show um
but I was producing all of like our e3
expo stages and it just wears on you
like that's a lot yeah
I wonder if I should bring all this
stuff I'm pretty like I'm gonna get rid
of my shotgun oh you all that stuff like
do you think I need the grenade launcher
a handgun a shotgun and a sniper rifle
because I feel like I don't I'm just
gonna go I'm bringing the Magnum just
because I think written toward the end
but I also alright just gave you 10 I
might not bring my handgun I know it's
dangerous but if we're getting towards
the final boss fight Lee I don't really
need it oh you're not there yeah but
yeah we're getting there ah give me your
hand guys give you my shock shells there
you go thanks I have two red and green
herbs Wow I have a green herb should I
not carry that either take it
we use those fast soon enough so my egg
egg run 2017 all right I'm gonna ready
up if it doesn't work we'll try again
I'm feeling it time's it no five Foley's
time for a vacation
yeah gonna do our looks tomorrow I'm
going to New Orleans tomorrow where
guess what also is going to New Orleans
tomorrow a hurricane oh sure can I
combine these greens or is that rude
there's a lot on for now unless you
really get it all right
I don't want that can you take it and
then our here here I'm giving you this
grid green then I'm gonna take this
Michigan mo for myself
hi de d-day all right um
so we're on that tanker now okay oh yeah
I remember this or we're walking down to
it at least every time I I go on
vacation some [ __ ] goes down like when I
went to Disney World last year mm-hmm
there was a hurricane maybe you should
stop traveling and hurricanes I did they
they're unpredictable no I'm saying
you're bringing them with you all right
we are on the tank won't be a problem
and it was we're here my family is from
Buffalo and we moved all over the
country when I was younger and every
what time we would go someplace they
would have like really bad snow and
they'd always blame my family and be
like you brought the snow from Buffalo
yeah Olivier is not our fall and we were
like adjusted to it you guys cry if it
snows I grew up like two hours east of
Buffalo maybe it was not until after you
put it look Rochester do you Sarah T's
do you want Plus huh do you wanna I
don't know what that is
goodnight launcher I don't know it's a
riot shock and I think so you might want
it since you're using a shotgun still
but I have a shotgun shotgun yeah but I
don't have any room give me uh your fold
I can drop some stuff hold on I can
combine these things I'm gonna combine
these things okay yeah cuz that cuff is
good you get it use that and then for
this chapter I think was a no are you
sure that's what it is yeah it said s G
in parentheses your uncle wait what's SG
mean shotgun gun makes sense
that's how people feel when you ask a
stupid question and then do that thing
that you do but you actually didn't know
I figured it out before you told me
though I feel like but I know I said it
never mind little Mary Axela submachine
gun what's going on here nothing that
concerns you
we're not giving you an option now spit
it out yes stupid accent both of you
tell us what we want to know when you
won't get hurt all three of you at
Westar
if you can behave yourselves maybe I'll
tell you sometimes these are really
disappointed I'll give it that much
massage all the time they've had so many
opportunities to talk to her and every
interaction is the same which is give us
the answers and then she's like I don't
think she can handle the truth and then
they're like we're gonna shoot you and
she's like you gotta catch me first and
then some [ __ ] goes down uh-huh it's
uncanny how readily you recounted all of
that um I'm gonna get there's like a
limo it's a [ __ ] green herb over here
and I can't take it
we're just so good at the game that's
the gate something tells me these are
flowers I like I'll look it I'll get
I'll get my guy to look into it oh look
what I found
there's those flowers again just how
much research do got an emblem flowers
need gonna power these computers on all
right I don't want to read researcher
Wow look cut these flowers it sounded
loud right what the crash yeah I mean I
guess a host of you go alright I'm gonna
go to the door I was gonna pick one of
these for you
[ __ ] wait you're not a flower girl want
a rifle this dude while we can you guys
well okay guess who doesn't have a head
stop leaning ruin my joke nope they
mustn't over here how they know we're
here now
I heard dumb oh I triggered the alarm
hey that was me I shot some dude why do
they get like reflex scopes in their aks
zombies don't have great eyesight what I
was gonna I need
[ __ ] sorry I'm dumb stomp it's not the
best vantage point oh there's handgun
ammo fire there's handgun ammo over here
do you want to pin down kind of okay
I'll shoot this guy should all three of
them actually good I'm there like yeah
thank you you think there's is there one
more there's two more okay I'm coming
that way anyway but I actually need to
hear this guy's on fire so I think that
one's okay and then there's this guy
hiding he's dead now
I'm not wasting my rifle ammo on that
loser sweet is that just you wanna maybe
go on one of us can be set here and
cover the other half my face yeah I'm
thinking too much it's resmio five not
[ __ ] go on having Rainbow six oh [ __ ]
he dodged me can't touch that touch this
don't I'll have what she's having
right [ __ ] different movies use quote
where we just quoted all right all right
I'm going getting people up top you get
people on the bottom oh watch out oh I
know I I know that was my fault
um Carlson I'm literally close to dying
get up don't do that we don't don't move
forward I got a heal quick we have a
[ __ ] ton of heals
I know but just don't move for now
there's a guy waiting what's our joke
that's him thank you I'm killing this a
mic
he's got grenades whoa whoo it so heal
up I did it oh never good
what about me I always pinned down it
plus we have enough do you want to take
this green herb and then use it cuz I I
could use it um all right hear me out
let's wait until you get hit again hmm
I'm not trying to be selfish just like
oh [ __ ] never mind I need it no no no
[ __ ] him
god damn it these eighties was always on
the [ __ ] stop thinking it's all good
all right wait let me where it was that
guy that shot you a lot took behind this
big container that your
hey the difficulty spikes and resin you
again like like from zero to a million
that guy's gonna helm it to [ __ ] I need
that handgun oh [ __ ]
I can't hit that guy because see they
expect us to be taking cover I'll [ __ ]
hate that but I mean that's a reasonable
thing I just remembered it's never
happened ever been needed I think he's
dead well good gonna wake it off the
wall off the world thanks
of course right got it all right gone
here I guess where are you going down
the ladder near yours oh yeah we gonna
do suck sorry
[ __ ] that using that thing that I said
about like yeah us being really good at
the game and not eating heels is like oh
it's not that sure zombies I hear a
zombie you got a decent shot it smell
like God he's got body armor honest
stoppies oh then he got it aim for his
head
nice oh do it again he's got a thing on
his head [ __ ]
got it okay suck he's still alive he's
dead
rap I have to [ __ ] off
there's no safe way to cross yeah thanks
groin stomp
if only they had a groin stomp seven out
of ten it's kind of generous for this
game
Oh is there a boss cuz there's yeah it's
so stupid but yes that guy you looks
shoot him a lot I haven't sent you her
grenades over here so I'm gonna throw
those okay
I have wasting ammo I have grenades as
well and I also have oh is that near me
okay good
where is he oh he's next to a big spell
to Barrow I'll come back if you can or I
shoot that one right next to her okay
I'm coming also our fur back here [ __ ]
damn
we use incendiary nice
[ __ ] you
Oh Morgan ain't on [ __ ] block
I'll go kick it now don't worry don't
worry
it's a [ __ ] ton of health and a stogie
well I'll be careful that looks like
you're about to hit a rally I think I
was fun it's really hard for me to get
him watching you do work though I'll
switch weapons I'm a nag him out kid
he should be close nicely how is he not
sky sucks oh [ __ ] oh wait he still shot
me oh yeah was against a wall that's
against wall rules there's something
we're not doing cuz this is ridiculous
he's even a year goes on
[ __ ]
come on dude is a resource like blow his
she hang up on the back no he's dead
okay that was dumb
all right cool key card I I'm low on
health again um there's a red er back
here
Oh is there I know that doesn't heal but
no no no here I have a green your
shotgun shells so you give me that in
take those shotgun shells back there
okay give uh where are the shotgun
shells
okay let me Leah okay ah [ __ ] I
shouldn't done that what you do use your
double green actually
why just good I think pretty sure those
low less ingredient red and I don't
never be wasting my Labor's much okay
all right are we going up here the
keycard Nutter that seems what was up
here then just the way to get above him
pretty sure I'm gonna look with us oh
sweet proximity bond I find it I use a
green herb sweet oh there's another um
exposure to there's another proximity
bomb over here we might have done that
incorrectly whatever he did though thing
say that to me now cuz he Dade okay
here's the key card there is a safe over
here that looks oh there's a second key
card valuable I don't want that machine
gun or that handgun any Boop cool
alright so now what back this door we
have okie needs
huzzah Rizk genève cards as they're
called gene gene
go clear oh not clear
get your rifle out maybe okay Oh II was
rude oh I get it so what are these
stupid [ __ ] logos on these things
no Rockets oh my god you still hit me
she must [ __ ] arm so you got body
armor everywhere [ __ ] I [ __ ] up where
we shoot him legs or arms all right that
guy's dead so yeah I hate this logo on
shows the other one the logo on the box
that guy's not dead I hate to be the one
to third one he's down here he's got no
kind of no I that gear though he is dead
now great so we're in agreement uh what
is that gold oh cool a necklace nice
which one of them was rocking a sweet
necklace the guy that I shot in the face
I care about two things in this world
rocket launchers and beautiful pearl
necklaces guys a really shitty aim with
an RPG but damn does he know a good
emerald he's murdered like over 40
people but my god does he know how to
accessorize all right Oh
I don't know her sohow bear report me to
this far too bad you won't make it much
further he's made out of gold
the news appear to go breed given birth
by the progenitor virus Spencer
Oswalt who's that guy Oswalt Spencer
thank you I don't remember this guy meet
him he's the one survived do that like
he ended all this [ __ ] it was just a
mansion we're in the first game oh I
could be wrong almost a hard day Gino
he reminds me of like the evil guy from
Star Wars help team one of them yeah
they're all pretty much the same the
loss in nightmares DLC you actually
replay some of this stuff like this
Albert whisker more like it your
creation still holds great significance
now why can't don't burn
Shane's chest isn't it for one who has
the right to be a god death murder from
behind to face tality the right to be a
god
I knew it
I've not seen this scene before hand he
went through him like that like he liked
her I said don't
ja I think that was Oswald Spencer I
could be way off
I never I'll not even until we get your
you're like the most area
God deserves Ross dialogue is so shitty
so redundant and bad I am the one who is
not conceited and deserves to be a god
and then someone else comes up and kills
and like no I am no I am the God if you
say to be a god I'm gonna [ __ ] I have
that right
to be a god that is in case you didn't
hear that much back that I imagine the
God viewing pleasure
oh my God we're really close isn't this
like six two or 6300 we're [ __ ] super
close also SATA sauce ah ah oo sauce ah
organized Celal which I learned from
comments
um can you give me that green so I can
come Bennett you don't have a room I was
gonna remove this mine can bin it and
then bring the mind back this is
calculated gonna buy that Chaka I don't
want this ha diggity dog I don't think I
need both shotguns so I'll get rid of
this shotgun I guess right
should I sell it look I'm not gonna use
it anymore right yeah uh yeah I would
say so
I really liked a shotgun
see ya
okay and now I will upgrade you because
you're now my new favorites
wait that's not that high oh my nuts
I've read my mag in a lot I actually
can't remember are we talking about um
did your music just change
yeah just soap opera yeah what the [ __ ]
was that what was weird did we
I turned the gameplay down because
something went wrong but let's see if
it's still there hold on I think it's
gone
what the [ __ ] what's going on I I think
it's gone right are we in a soap opera
is this off as haunted The Crucible is
done what is that from okay anyway I'm
readying up does your PC have a video
playing possibly might be an
advertisement that was kind of funny
though let's ignore it until it might
happen again
oh my god I'm so confused I hope like it
was like nope the recording picked it up
we were late where's Kevin no we're not
crazy all of a sudden we were like in a
rom-com weird you're gonna start
devolving and saying just like ohe tasty
and you'll become a fan zombie who said
vampire vams aaahm be the famous vampire
series Resident Evil really is this
shocking to you you've killed like 6500
of those things
uh-uh what's going on
Oh Commander Shepard oh I hear that
Worcester there is a video playing
somewhere young mission is at its hand
I'll take care of you he borrows is on
the eve of its appearance six billion
cries of agony will burn a new ballot I
think a YouTube videos playing I thought
of all of us I thought they were puns
Westra doesn't give a damn about anyone
even you London that fresh one glimpse
of my new world that was weird
I think you're right I think it's an
advertisement I can xrs the right
unfortunately all right if again land
for you you will not live to see the dog
sorry but it appears full of Lawrence
has rejected you do you have been at
four
last time for you I never loved you
[Music]
is this the final boss fight have you
heard like anything about the final boss
fight this game I think there's a brach
involved yep upholder pretty bad this is
cool this is cool in in the final one I
didn't bring a handgun yeah oh yeah
sorry I hate hate hate been consistent
that eight I don't want a boss fight not
disagreeing with that like it's like I
know but it doesn't make me prepare for
[ __ ] touchpad this [ __ ] you got it
I hate quick time of it alright ready
get your square ready well don't rely on
a being square might be X square another
one I'm sure God Circle was not circle
what was Circle Square OHS oh it's
different for us
heck that's circle X shut up it's
different for both of us you're screwing
me no way yes it's different there
probably know that something like this
was happening like we're gonna [ __ ] over
those crews get up here you dick run
this sucked
oh my god
this sucks alright here we go
[Music]
that's Mass Effect where is that coming
from give me a second that's the ending
spoilers did you hear that I mean you
can rewrite I'm with you check
everything on there um get rid of it um
open up this and just like nope you need
that okay I don't know where it's coming
from
oh do you have play on stop you don't
want it playing possible we're playing a
recording is that what it was
maybe oh my god we have a uh sorry well
we we made sure do a backup audio
recording we have attached to him Mary's
going away for a week we have a task
camera we record and I think what
happened was I think we had record and
play on it how to cover didn't kick in
till then um oh it's it's possible that
it was on this whole time and we just
didn't notice I mean it's not like it's
that loud is this hurting it or am I
wasting my time I think you're wasting
your time I could be wrong that I've
been no it looks like it is wasting time
hurting it handling just let's just
ignore missing any money or something
probably and uh and a chalice or sweetie
I was looking for both of those uh sweet
you
yeah I think it is wasting time to do
that right now you just avoid it yeah I
think so
so this is Excel that we're seeing
everywhere right the boobie lady from
the cutscene hell yeah her implants
finally rejected her that's mean she had
really nice boobs good
that can't happen though I read about it
in the magazine I can turn you into a
barge size and monster yes well what
magazine was that sick sad world
why can't
it's actually the news from Korea [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's on me
what do you want me to do about it think
I'm just complaining you look really
weird I do yeah there's something on
your face
you got a deadly virus with your class
uh here okay you give me your one of
your proximity mines sugar actually just
get the one you have sure and then he'll
pick up that green herb over there okay
I can't combine it though sorry
actually I for now you should give me
the mines pick up the greening trustee
mind and come VIN it wit click and then
I'll give you these back just hold onto
those mm-hmm
the president what are we doing in here
I gotta go farther down the hallway I
guess over this way
uh-oh this doesn't look good
what's wrong this hallway just like that
this looks like the cyborg ninja hallway
from rimmel Gear Solid 1 where all those
dead don't stuff on their chakra tons I
would assume oh look this really ok so
the shock batons do all of a sudden 75%
damages pointing the game [ __ ] you
stop I need to heal
ok wait give me some of that heart all
right I'm ready
I you know what's funny is I'm not sure
if that audio will be recorded it might
not be no no that we probably won't cuz
I was the backup I think we have to
separate outs so I'm not sure so you'll
have to check it to see I'd rather it
didn't but I promise you there's friggin
weird audio I was getting all that
Mary's crazy oh my god alright new year
I love when you were like that's the
ending of Mass Effect it was like why
does it sound familiar there's like
there are tons of stars there's there's
a little bunch of stars and we're just
one story out of a million lore knows
you know what that was that was the
beginning of a reboot episode maybe this
is an SD card that Jake and I recorded
on our mass effect that actually could
be it cuz we use that ending battening
or pretty funny if that's the case
handgun oh stuff to read sweet I can't
turn off automatic navigation is that
what we're doing oh it's one of those
polls that the stripper is so BAE
already if we don't do something able to
show up are we getting on Trevor it's a
coin of this poll structural support are
we getting on the hyper getting out of
turn my body oh axela needs structural
support ah
swing swing okay there's a writer up
there but we can worry about that after
I think coming back here we're locked
out there's like an under part down here
oh wait no this is where it came from
I'm dumb sorry I'm coming back up
shotgun shells over here sorry I got
confused there's an above part I have a
keycard did I tell you that we're both -
oh actually just come up here you'll
need a Bragg um how'd you get up there
my follow this blue starter shotgun
shells right down Brook hmm what's this
red thing yeah okay not a light laser we
just might have a chance
oh that was important getting devices on
the roof come on there's no time to lose
I'm right here
I was here first rifle and I will take
that rifle but I can't take anything
else all right what's the plan actually
wait hold on I'm gonna get that add one
round just take enough space
take the incendio blue mouse consume me
it's me that hot girl from before it's
inflamed I wonder what we have to shoot
I'm pretty sure there are turrets I
could be grossly wrong oh yeah I think
so
use keycard quick over here oh whoa no
shadows the space yeah you do shoot that
[ __ ] I'm gonna climb up here what am i
doing do that thing I guess what did I
do it lock-in the hammer of dawn I think
you did it yeah shoot her now maybe this
is he arrived on shoot that big thing
oh it's charging
I shoot that they call this thing
okay it's charged shoot this no one yeah
there you go
so stupid
this is the hammer of dawn now we just
shoot the face while this game came out
thank except it's not daylight based
what you guys it the last one
oh it's charging I can't do anything I
don't know if I'm wasting ammo or not so
I'm gonna i got flame around here today
launcher check oh wow you charged
a weird game this thing you just have to
keep doing that like what did how is
this hard I don't know I mean I don't
want James said you've got hurt by
something I know there's [ __ ] on the
ground I have another what's the point
of me shooting anything like I don't
know what I can use Oh God
I kind of need you to uh yeah yeah I'll
shoot those things you just concentrated
I don't know what I need hell don't know
can you climb up here Thanks
oh [ __ ] we just exchanged exchanged
would positions stay up there all right
I need help though I don't come up and
there's all these balls I just start
shooting you I guess all right I think
oh you can't be up there I guess why not
I don't know I guess after a while she
hit the top this is don't just ready up
I'm sucking food she hit that upper
platform so we should go up and not go
up I don't know there's team sweet wait
do you want it don't you want that
incendiary sorry okay let's get this
[ __ ] touchpad
you're ugly and nobody likes you all
right we don't get to stuff up cobbler
back all right
I'll hit ball number one
flame rounds up here sink [ __ ] yeah hit
those old goo balls on the ground I got
along give me a second
okay ball number two up what he hit his
own he hit his ball it'll come back I'm
not worried
wait he's doing something
it's swung up here are you dead no but
it was annoying
here in the face that he I'll shoot
these things alright so now we get the
four balls up top right well now you got
hit the big one now Oh twice I think
I'll get these things all right well
it's charging so just be careful we're
done incendiary gonna go god damn you
you little [ __ ] not only how you do
anything get some big ones great
oh these little things are awful
dropping our
got him
yeah
ooh lot of herbs holy [ __ ] okay now we
have four three of those do just drop
herbs great I'm not super hurt yet but I
am slowly getting hurt and I don't want
to do this again well they're ugly yeah
just stay in that corner I guess until
he/she swings you got it
did I miss
yeah but whatever all right this gun is
so big it seems ridiculous I'm gonna
shoot the one on the right so don't hit
the one on the reich's I think I'm gonna
try to see if I get damaged get ready
for a Dodge yep
oh my god I don't want to lose shitty
battle what's going on oh my god
all right I think I could just hurry
with oh good do that then I bet she the
one on the right
don't hit that one that's what I'm
working on all right I'll get the one on
the Left I guess Oh little thing hold on
wrap are you dead
no kind of heal up let me uh peel up
stop moving
all right I got one yeah coming over
he'll do it I got to pick up all those
other ones quick watch out I got
stupid thing
what are all these grenades for
Thanks
we just throw grenades at them [ __ ]
running at me yeah I'm trying to go on
it they look around I do those things on
the ground of the spirit temple and that
things are now the fire temple that's
way above in ocarina of time
all right all right I got
oh [ __ ]
are you dad nope I get hit open up your
stupid balls I'm sick of this [ __ ]
I'll keep healing yous
one more
hit me a little dudes fun
careful dude no don't waste grenades on
it it's too late
future reference I'm gonna oh my god
watch out no I'm good
alright should be it
no no got it already hit space all right
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
all right 50 that again on this
[Music]
die [ __ ] scum I'm stuck
they're gonna be like 6 on now are you
serious this has been a long even that
are just annoying it's not anyone agreed
two more looks like I wish there's
another [ __ ] I wonder if there is
gonna top all of you I gotta heal oh god
heal please don't die
it's not worth it I don't need you just
yell god I don't know yet calm down I
have to hell okay doesn't matter
now we're both yeah pick that up I'm
gonna need more help oh god you're
making me nervous
sorry I just don't do it again I know
but we're fine okay I'm sorry
stop moving your lip I have a lot of
herbs they're dropping more than you
realize okay stop moving
oh my god
Oh God be very careful like I said I've
a [ __ ] ton of help stop it
these things are stupid FAST only okay
actually maybe I need to stun them so
you can [ __ ] on we're on the right hit
the one on the right okay I think it
helps you if I hurt them and then they
sit on them okay yeah you're right
I need more little dudes for health data
every cup sweet I am this is charging a
little bit you're taken care of for now
um
when this is done charging stun that
dude up top
what do oh yeah yeah yeah I got a
dodging first it looks like yikes
Oh another one
want it now correct hi I'm ready wait
alright you can get it now looks like it
all right here we go here we go [ __ ]
don't do that anyway the little dudes
they're not dropping health any more but
we're doing all right
currently we're okay my god
yeah hit that one ever that [ __ ] that
better [ __ ] be it's a shitty boss man
at least you can do is follow the rule
three really are you are you hit it
again I guess I got it in a second
nobody died all right [ __ ] load of them
strop hell so
I got two balls over here
you're right
I'll stun this one when you're ready
okay I also if I shoot it it's also just
stops it from attacking us so it can't
help her to shoot it chicken on my end
Oh little dudes heads up my bad okay
okay I'm ready I got a thought [ __ ]
no [ __ ] okay this is done it all
right there you go
should work I'll heal you in case okay
look I just don't I didn't really
something wrong I don't know that's the
problem with most of this game yeah I
don't I don't know I think a lot of it
is just like being persistent I shot
like six times the machine gun and that
was all we needed to do well I mean
that's so stupid that the difference
[ __ ] that
an axela and everything she stands for
alright she's dead now we're close okay
I think this is the next one is the last
chapter hey check out my ABS what abbs
okay I'm gonna hit okay let's finish
this you ready
[Music]
cha-cha-cha
hey you feeling okay oh if this is it
I'm gonna upgrade everything well I
don't know that but it's gotta be her so
much Alice's ahead in Magnum mo here's
the here's the past
not everyone what no I don't want spoil
anything okay okay let's go
all right I'm ready there's new buys
applicant I'm in the zone
what am I gonna do with all these
proximity mines so that goes I don't
know god damn it Wesker oh wait she
didn't just press we're drawing the
entire planet oh maybe that was the way
we're supposed to go because this is a
way we came from so doesn't really make
any sense I'm gonna come up another self
another oh wait we're just going back to
same way we came
I guess means anything up there no we're
good
I killed her no oh now we can go back
through those passageways they used to
be blocked all right right her body
her boobs are blocking her boobs for
blocking everything
ah swell spending at all as well as
anything we're like Patton Oswald we're
just north I was Walton were normal and
Boswell but yeah be when Jill said
Wesker was planning to spread the rumors
throughout the world he's planning to
use this to spread it
Wes curry there is one hi it's me the
god Jill are you alright I need to tell
you
let's go superhuman strength it comes
from a virus but the virus isn't stable
in order to maintain a balance he must
inject himself regularly with a serum so
because the supply of serum uses the
strength
affirmative but he just took a dose so
it's gonna be a while before he need
another one it's also that the amount
administered had to be precise so if he
injects too much it should act like a
poison I didn't use the survey with PG 6
7 8 w PG 670 delta T that's my mom's
name you need to find that serum ticks
are always test it with her that should
take Jill come in Chris
this is it
wait where did she get that let's give
it a shot where was that
um I'm soaking her she picked it up at
some point getting shot down Oh exactly
vendors when you get shot down if it
does will initiate a biohazard get in
here the name of the series of Japan
virus worldwide exactly way where'd you
get that shot Showa shaiva where did she
get that where have I heard six seven
eight w before what was the point of
that camera make me dizzy stay up here
well he's dead I think hopefully um I do
we want to go there
maybe I don't [ __ ] know but I'm gonna
try good luck
wait
guide your right
you get on the ground stab you through
the water get on the ground
stoppies die
nice
just
[Music]
lover
[Music]
there's a green plan over here but I'm
full [ __ ] you sorry that came out of
nowhere get that guy's bigger than
normal
they keep coming from above now let's
just keep moving in the ball cancer
oh [ __ ] just come over this is where are
you oh there's a gate here yeah with the
UH one of those [ __ ] everybody I
don't know I mean I [ __ ] will
maybe this is one of those things though
they we like don't do it in time we dyes
probably what are you knowing this [ __ ]
what I mean what hit no no no no no get
off the wall
I'm sorry you're here okay fine all
right what is going on oh here we go
it's open let's jump across it was
killing people based oh my god really
he's got to go my god I'm dying again
all right
I've got health or something you're
gonna die so careful for me heal up
with you
all right wait wait just let me just
like kill them or something
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] RPG Ethan he's dead who
did guy over there oh I almost did stuff
jump over vault there's a better word
for that let me heal you and me okay
[Music]
hurry up I think oh [ __ ] I guys got a
refugee where I got him very much
come on he's dead okay I'll go press
this lever on their side okay and go
probably enough to wait here until it's
gonna open slowly [ __ ] everything in
this game is so slow for a while oh god
of course the [ __ ] bugs are here yeah
oh you got to shoot those spots on it
remember working on it show me your bugs
all right so my sweet little bud one
more old mark excuse me I have to reload
dude right here
[ __ ] me he's gonna kill me really really
it was a one hit kill if you grab me
like that
[ __ ] I hope when do you think it uh when
do you think it like um okay I'm gonna
we're gonna be should stick together cuz
I don't have wait done should I put a
proximity mine down yeah that'd be
actually a good idea
I'm not sure if don't put them right
next to each other though so they don't
blow up at the same time yeah over there
okay let's do it
you ready yeah let me remember to shoot
their things I got it shoot things
there's also a ladder right next to you
that leads from the bottom I don't know
if they're coming on that way um okay so
you get things that are near I'll get
things that are far got it okay get that
bug oh [ __ ]
on get open this thing oh god damn it
open your chest
[Music]
approximately mine hit
[Music]
I can't see his other one
he [ __ ] dead or not yeah proximity
mines help good
I stink open yet no it's close though
take cover as fast as you can when we
jump over he's got it
maybe we killed him faster than more
honest is anything down here use for
word we know we already down there
alright let's just [ __ ] will happen the
noise is stopped noising open me [ __ ]
you like the last middle finger you're
an idiot dude no you are
oh my god two of them
[Music]
all right we need cover come back this
way
[ __ ] run oh my god is it got me I can't
I can't [ __ ] Vega get cover
oh there's guys here too you kill I'll
shoot those as the magnetars kill these
two guys are here
Oh didn't wanna jump over [ __ ] you
kick himkick him ticking ticking all
right oh my [ __ ] god
where are they coming from next to you
behind you hiding that dude I didn't
mean to do that
[Music]
do you want me to put another pucks in
mind they're going up crap damn it I'm
almost dead get out of here
oh I'm deep [ __ ]
no I'm not coming
you died first yeah okay on this part
annoying well I think if both of us are
like dying
there's no point we can say to each
other Oh hopefully we got a checkpoint
after the bugs cuz if we didn't that's
[ __ ] stupid alright so I have I buy
anything right now for this fight
because this seems annoying oh sure mmm
bulletproof vests maybe our first date
so I got my proximity mines back so I
think we did lose it
Oh
gesina let's do you know we should do we
should back up much farther than where
we just yeah okay so do those process we
actually no don't waste those yet don't
use those I think we're good with a bug
there's only two bugs so don't use the
proximate I accidentally gave them you
okay let's just pull the levers and
you're ready for the bugs but stick
close together okay we have much more
room to work with them we just used in
this area we can each take a bug don't
we each get a bug yeah [ __ ]
right alright he's he's stunned
Niki's
nice he's dead all right cool where's
the other one fraid he's coming I'm
reloading
all right I'm ready I heard him shoot
that thing
simple enough right so is he dead
yeah nope yeah okay cool so put the
proximity mines down well we don't we
don't need to worry about that until the
gate [ __ ] does it's nine out but you
have the time yeah all right
okay I'm putting one right here let's
just [ __ ] spread them out cuz like
the problem is these these dudes come
from the [ __ ] snow yeah I'm gonna
save the last one let's back up to even
behind here cuz they come they come from
behind us I know but come back here
alright so keep in mind we can jump down
over where is it now there's a crater
right here - yes and we can go up these
stairs which might be more helpful
we're down over this way oh maybe that's
what we should do our office ladder are
probably better mm-hmm
yeah come up this way [ __ ] you're fine
you got time you sure
[Music]
where are you I went up the stairs just
let him hit the pucks here yeah oh that
is it the first one oh that's good okay
cool
no no no we're shooting at me he all
right I got my Magnum out you shoot
these minor dudes
all right come down come down this way
follow me down these stairs to your left
we got it you got it
Oh God all right I've got a lot of
healing things come up no I'm fine but
oh sure we can come behind him okay let
me see which way they're coming because
I can put approximately mine down all
right I'm pulling right here gonna let
this guy come at us all right this guy's
gonna jump they're coming down here yes
you fine all right this red ones about
to walk on the one that's up go move to
your right look you're right I'm trying
no no no no you're good no no no there's
a guy there all right focus on these
guys right now they're he's going on all
right let's you just stuff the feeds
abouts get move to your right like
immediate right let's dude [ __ ] we can't
stay here I know but I got a loo no it's
all right all right this guy right here
we can't stay here I know I'm not I'm
moving out just kick in
oh god we got a run come over here
where are you one it's one cell yeah I
got a heal I think once dad come here in
the Hmong hyung I gotta go to the side I
had to get out of there there's oh I see
you yeah stay so dope
[ __ ] dope I'm trying I was combining
behind right behind you what just
happened oh we got flashbang
whoa oh I guys got your nades heads up
so there's one I think the both big dude
you're a lot nope red ones right there
how about up these stairs uh yet mmm
oh my they come back here he's right
here guess what I found
seriously now we find it just waste him
right
pushing about that an hour ago I would
have been great where's the other one
got a hangar key card I got pick up the
other one it's rightfully mine shocked
and I went down here wait are they both
dead yeah they are kept okay
key cards let me hook up all the animal
they're missing I can't believe that was
there the whole time the whole time
that's all right we did it a lot of [ __ ]
for you all right do you want to worry
right I'm gonna wait for you here come
over this way
um I have handgun ammo and I gotta give
you acid okay wait here let me get this
soon give me that machine yo anyway
there's give I'm um I can't give you any
of the show um give her this
what do you want more um machine gun or
handgun well I can have both just give
me the machine gun personnel reload and
then we give you this asset browns
should be good even a lot of shotgun
ammo so don't skimp on the shotgun you
got it
sweet okay my first date I bought the
first day spur and I feel like when we
go through here it's gonna save so [ __ ]
I didn't put I didn't use those first
aid sprays I bought I didn't put those
in my inventory
haha Shane's a 2000 gold that's funny
like I give a [ __ ] about 2000 gold we've
been through so much gold something
doesn't feel right don't start with me
you get through this Shiva Shiva Shiva
[Music]
failing in your mission
sometimes you've really become quite an
inconvenience for me
[Music]
why did you catch that
what that guy is so dumb
stabbing with the thing have him shaiva
hazard Killa
why is she why are you doing this
what are you accomplished by Alicia gorg
whirls every day humans come one step
closer to self-destruction I'm not
destroying the world I'm saving it
stop shooting him like she knows how to
do it but she keeps shooting him I don't
understand
I thought we like how to plan how else
would have this Sean Witt face-off well
you're dumb may be our only chance we
discussed those do it what things are
getting interesting now hey Chris
[Music]
either way I'm not gonna stop until I'm
dead well there
I'll just have to kill
[Music]
here's an idea what if we say well oh
I'm dying joke something what is this
Tara - I'm just gonna run from him
because he sucks well there's an RPG in
here yeah forgot what these levers do
like what's what's the plan like what do
I do with this no idea I figure out that
love I just pulled a lever Oh lever over
there you [ __ ] like this guys [ __ ] me
up an RPG round well what am I doing
with this RPG really doubt it like I
don't think that's what you're supposed
to do you're right clear yeah we got to
stun him somehow I knew it I don't know
what that lever did that I just pulled
pull that one too
[Music]
yeah she run away from him for now and
then I think pulling these levers does
something
[Music]
I already pulled this one
because it never occurred to you that
this planet is overpopulated there's
like a lot of people here so now I can't
pull this lever over here
[Music]
it is all them RPG rounds here do you
want those yeah keep them up and load it
but what are you doing with it
I don't know don't shoot him with I
don't know as much as you I'm just
saying
oh here we go this week he's gonna throw
the show okay so you need to hit it with
those right I don't know I'll try it out
and not positive that means a heads up
yes you're the one that's gonna rule
this I'm gonna try to show you come here
and just see if it doesn't know he's
gone from there no I think here's the
suit hi literally it's here um see if we
can just stun him like we used to in the
other fight he's coming toward us right
now
Oh like right there please yeah let's
try that for now and we'll figure it out
yeah like wait until he's now shoot
ha
oh god help me
here toward Mandy head he's talking me
up
I remember this he catches the [ __ ]
rocket and then you have to de toutes it
I think or something okay so yeah wait
for him to like come at you and then
I'll be vulnerable and then should come
at me
damnit come at me yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay now go now I got to get away from
him I don't know I get there you guys
nice now go up and stab him you can do
it now give him a shot
I don't you have it I thought sorry get
it there was no time I think we got a
hit with you what house okay but now we
know it's due you just have to literally
shoot it right in the chest
oh we need way more help are you there
no no I mean we're good we're just we're
just being down with when he was just
don't let him like corner you know you
got to grab a rocket round I'll try to
this yeah what do you mean don't you
need to go to people need to load it
that's what we did before
oh so grab one come over this way [ __ ]
I'm dying I'll heal you death not much I
can do if you're good I'm not I'm not
dealing with this [ __ ] today I've been
trying to stay positive but I will it
doesn't last very long you're the one to
start making fun of me it's okay though
no it's not how does dad all right um
you want to get the RPG sure no I'll
shoot him actually let me do it doorbell
that one's already loaded it was easier
up top let's go up top that's the only
one no I'm just saying that one's
already loaded sure you're ready to go
[ __ ]
[ __ ] all right you ready yeah
okay here we go come to you coming
backwards keep backing in
Oh dick I don't think you're supposed to
do it then you gotta grab around
[Music]
I grabbed the RPG
I think we got to get away from him
actually press l1 to drop the RPG I'll
shoot him I grabbed that round
I'm not you yeah look it up over this
way do now
all right just give me a second to dose
Eidos here yeah keep going down this
long stretch I liked it better here
because I have these like ultimate areas
to dodge him and stuff like this is a
nice corner for me cuz I can use these
as like corners to get away from him all
right what how did he dodged that well
we're not supposed to do it then Mary
that's when I shot him last time I'm the
one that shot him but he was what would
you suggest when he attacks he just did
attack I was looking at attack right
here you gotta see that see it I don't
have
[Music]
come on
we should have to go around this corner
should we get I'll wait for him to be
fully stunned next time yeah let me even
if I have to take some damage like let
me try to stun him and smoosh it I'm
didn't do my best
I can't believe we had to do this
multiple times alright okay I pretty
sure I did it when he had us gone out
last night oh really
[ __ ] I guess I'm done [ __ ] uh all right
sorry okay I was trying to pass him I
did a bad job of it I need you to help
me right now I know I can't make her
move faster I was coming oh my god this
guy sucks
oh my god I'm [ __ ] gonna die again I
had to do that it's not them Jesus he
just does like 80 attacks in a row so
annoying um when you get the chance
getting RPG round no rush
oh [ __ ] I can't pass him I need to wait
all right now I can do it like the idea
of doing this three times is actually
heartbreak I don't know if we have two
or three times I just think we need to I
need to be ready to get closer of a
stabbing with a shot like I am actually
not positive how we did it yeah
oh that's fair enough but I know I like
this corner because I can dodge him in
the corner it's just really hard to do
it in a straight line because I can't go
past him in any way fast little [ __ ]
also my Health's really love
[Music]
okay I'm dying oh man [ __ ]
I have I need help
- might as well just try and soon we
might die now
nice socks wonderful I don't understand
what to do like we did it and I still
don't understand the nuances of it I'm
eating this right now Mary let's be
positive we're figuring out it's a fun
it's a fun let's think of it as fun
maybe it'll become fun I'm coming I
don't know if I'm going to make you care
you go did you get any green herbs
[Music]
all right there's one behind us can you
[ __ ] off for a [ __ ] second yeah
oh I could just load it myself which I
knew that just all right come on come at
us
I need that herb oh you can counter
attack him I don't know that I think all
right so you can counter attack him so
they'll see because I I don't even know
if any other [ __ ] like I have a couple
in first days praising it because I
definitely like loaded the first grenade
I like remember doing and shooting into
space town I got a bunch of first date
sprays great see what I don't need these
flash I hate this boss there maybe I'll
bring these flash bangs maybe a little
help actually gonna give it to you see
if maybe you can stun over something
that's fine it's a touchpad cutscene Oh
oh my god Ida Marbury you're screaming
the mic I just started with half health
because that [ __ ] hit me as soon as it
started Mary you're screaming like game
sucks I know we're almost done with it
we'll celebrate right
I got it all right without women it is
because you there were a couple times
were you okay
what there are definitely a couple times
where you hit him and it's done and then
I can hit it I remember that it's like I
need him to come to me and then I need
to counter-attack yeah maybe
come on how do you dodge that I just
don't know you think that would be good
time to do it
um no boy what do you slippers do on it
I'm gonna go get some my rocket coming
up these things them but I do think like
we don't we don't want to shoot at him
unless he's in a stun State like it
doesn't work
[Music]
she get a rocket yet I'm always there
cuz she's cheap
I can't Pat we can't pass him how did
you do that
grandma oh I tried to do that like ten
times
well [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm almost dead
I'm dead he's the [ __ ] bane of mines
assume he's all that hard to get around
I'm dying
I know help me I'm having a great time
[Music]
listen I'm gonna the game is gonna be
over I'll come here uh here : hmm yes
you get five
let me come heal you actually all right
pawn don't pick that up pick up the
round there we go okay I'm loaded I'm
coming to you right now
great oh dang that takes way too long
girl oh I'm gonna call me Ellie he's
gonna - to go around this corner
nope oh my god I push me away from you I
used it I didn't use it but I press okay
stop oh there we go I'll pick out the
RPG shooter if you can dodge them are at
speed
yeah yeah I got it shoot him shoot him
with it alright shoot him from behind no
no no no no no no now with RPG pot on uh
I'll tell you one
[Music]
this guy is sucks don't shoot me I'm not
I think Khan I think he's got a KO
toward you and then I could shoot him in
the back of this and then stun him come
to closer yet you're not
there we go oh I hit him I don't know if
it counts oh [ __ ] are you okay
[Music]
god I hate this boss you gotta learn him
toward you so I can shoot his back okay
you're gonna I think and just get ready
to [ __ ] him he keeps going to the
closest person and it's annoying yeah
you got to like go closer to him so he
can comfort you you're backing up and
then you I pressed the counter-attack
yeah
Oh No
[Music]
yeah like come closer to when you have
the RPG and then he'll come toward you
or I'll have the RPG I'll lure him
toward me and then shoot in the back get
ready to die to shower here yes we can
return I'll get it boss
operas all three all right there's no
point
Jinna shut up let's go all right so wait
for it let me see if I can looking at me
an opening huh huh yeah I'll get a vest
important like I was able to distract
him once before
all right shooter the backbeat the
chance nice cool nope I couldn't I'm too
close you got him
no I'm dodging on to it it's too late I
know Mary you understand I'm Dodger I'm
trying to UM do it now okay do now
how did dodge that you saw me do it son
I don't know it must not be the right
way to do it
oh that's your like what else
I mean that's hurting and I think it's
not like we sought the stabbing but I
don't even know like I don't understand
what we did the first time yeah me
neither
maybe I just the timings off and I was
let me get around
[Music]
is he up here yes oh my god I think this
this game sucks
[Music]
all right got my rocket ready to go
[Music]
yeah yeah I'm coming toward him so go
wafer to blow of it to go hit him I'm
coming coming so get him come come up I
might it might not work but whatever
it's you it's you really but right so I
shot him like in the back oh when he was
like facing me are you almost dead no
Larry stop [ __ ] screaming in the mine
no it's hurting my ears you to like
learn to deal with things thank you very
you're screaming in the mic fine no it's
not it's like literally annoying to
watch Rep cancel all right I'm gonna die
thank you for saving it by the way
uh-huh
I'll try it I gotta nice nice nice
all right do you have the RPG yeah I'll
put snacks I don't know why it didn't
work
I'm gonna kiss me all right so I think I
can just I know what I did all right dad
I'm going upstairs can you huh you just
like bring my mic back up or what
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
all right so maybe it is from behind
that works I'm gonna restrain him
alright go toward him I'm right next to
Julie go do a shot yeah it literally
didn't give me a button cross-eyed it's
fine this way
all right so get the grenade okay he's
coming toward you tell ya I gotta get
this out so annoying
yes let me reload it quick
I'm good so stick over there and would I
wait until eise
[Music]
I just keep certainly for now so you get
hurt you know I'm gonna get these RPG
rounds out of the thing wait I got an
idea so you get those things load it
great load it and then I'm gonna try to
get to come down here which will bring
his back yeah but I'm closer to follow
me right now maybe you're right you
probably right that is his back I'm
gonna shoot all right yeah I'll do get
ready to run up to him oh my bad
I walked under too fast hey he's coming
to me all right no point
I'm gonna weigh from the polls gone out
that's why I have to work I don't want
to waste these arrogance
boom all right hey don't restrain him
yet I'm coming all right
you ever straight dope John yes yes it's
better [ __ ] beating is that it one
more time the shop oh my god okay but
Mary yeah leave me if I said that was
not the end of the Western chronic it
has to be I couldn't be did it work
I think so is this the end snake man
somebody's get away hurry
[Music]
she's so weak
[Music]
all right so here's my suggestion
uh-huh call the episode here and we
finish up it's not going to be crazy
long but I think it would be a really
long episode if we finish it now but we
could do it right after this but how
much longer is it it's gonna be able to
like like we can still be the game but I
highly suggest stopping it here and then
doing another episode right after it's
it's just a long episode you Chris yeah
but if this is at the end is like 10
minutes from now just do it it's more
than 2 minutes but you're probably ready
she's probably good
I say we end on this cliffhanger because
I think it gets even more annoying
before we all right let me figure out
this cutscene less than 5 minutes we
reach the optimal altitude Ouroboros
will be released into the atmosphere
blow saturation oh my god my bad hey cut
me you're so right it's always before a
boss but I hate these things
I suck at them and I hate them just
let's just kill this [ __ ] it's not bad
this right ready
Square will be released into the
atmosphere sharing complete global
saturation it's just gonna be a series
of cutscenes again is it I'm ready I got
my X's and my squares ready my r2 l2
your feeble attempts delay
Genesis is at hand and I will be the
creator
Square
oh you got stabbed
get ready did you think
it just said Sheva on my screen wait
didn't I do that before hey I think we
both had one oh I remember where they
got it but go for the over cover me Oh
sever do it good swear
just like that movie get off my plane
get off my plane you can dodge bullets
but he can't I think it was called the
president's planes
I was called maybe one
a force in
no if only this were the end wait what's
happening
who's that Jill hey did you press
anything I did
I really did it's fine this game sucks I
prided myself on gonna start over Oh
ensuring complete global saturation time
to bring these the ps4 and Xbox one they
couldn't just move this dumb [ __ ] I
can't oh he keeps get out watch out here
we go yeah get on your squares and your
exes I got I got my square done so it
next will be you
okay let's get this and I think the next
ones you - yeah okay so this is just you
okay l 2r - it might be different
consider that this key okay you can like
Audie ibly here me [ __ ] like these
buttons I'm in no mood of volcano right
now yeah I didn't leave that I goes
walking out get off me oh that was get
off my plane wait
so we die right no I wish that would be
a better ending
I feel like we should die in said
scenario
oh my god so we're like boiling on the
inside
yeah oh my god
I don't need any of this ah [ __ ] my bad
eyes here just look right below what is
that salient care anywhere we need this
[ __ ] remember needs shooting it my dad
oh I don't
it's fine thank you we've a bunch of
zombies come out of the lava like we're
ending the episode yep
[Music]
yea-ah did you shoot his shirt off I
should have killed you years ago
oh my god Chris Chris take get ready for
so [ __ ] fun press again alright I got
it yeah getting started
so this is the final boss fight yeah so
this looks final but hear me out
don't worry about shooting me yet I
don't think I literally think we just
have to keep moving around and running
and pressing in Qigong you'll seem to
die he looks like the dude from
prototype now
Europe like that no okay wait
yes prototype two is not half [ __ ]
personal husband
I remember prototype two like jumping
around and stuff you know okay so he's
got that red heart thing I think we have
to deal with right now okay but I'm
gonna run run up this back
yeah keep up keep running this way don't
worry about shooting this is a jumper
did we actually have to yeah wait
Evan no blue my fault oh no you're good
he's normal
yeah keep running though like there's
gonna be a path keep going along it
alright um yeah [ __ ]
you shouldn't get the XD pants wait your
nighttime her it just looks that way
okay [ __ ]
not entirely I think I went too far I
might die just to prepare you like I
can't hold ya are you I'm not sure how
I'm supposed to help you but oh really
care all right here we go skip this wait
mmm-hmm I don't think we even need any
of this [ __ ]
so just ready up um I was just gonna
remove this because if we don't then I'd
like to take a health because like it
seems like a health is more important
[ __ ]
many of you go first
so keepers running along the path that's
there I won't go there's two paths it
breaks yeah it goes up and down both
left go up they did last go up this
Boulder uh-huh yeah jump down okay and
then punch it sounds stupid but
oh okay it's really dumb playing a video
to try to shoot up look okay alright I'm
shooting them it's not doing much but I
get ready he's he's right next to you
okay
well [ __ ] I'm gonna die totally my fault
I should have been shooting it more
sorry about that
alright so we're getting we're figuring
it out a little more so like we're dying
our priority line here priority for you
right now yeah do the same thing get to
the boulder go up but then the whole way
I'm gonna be shooting it more to try to
slow down cuz then I can join up with
you and we can do
[Music]
sweet so yeah just do your thing
say I'm shooting him it's not doing much
nothing anything I'm gonna do my best
square there okay I slowed down l so
dumb X X square Circle Square uh sweet
literally punch that Boulder sure did
okay so now run up to that edge
someone save me when I do okay he is
kind of close to you I slum down as much
as I could
I'm running but yeah just don't don't do
it yet uh I can't run across maybe is
this normal
don't know alright um he's very close to
me um tell me you have babies here now
now try just
[Music]
that definitely was what I was supposed
to do like I was supposed to jump across
yeah I have no idea why didn't I oh why
why even the ending of four was like
[ __ ] short for me yeah there before
you finished really easily the vice boss
fighting no the the water bike seemed
like I I like hated that cuz I was like
I can go like I don't know how was she
supposed to get there besides the
boulder I did everything like I was
[ __ ] like super ready and I I don't
I'm super confused square square square
squares where you might need to let go
and shoot him I didn't slow him down
enough I don't think oh my god I don't
think I can
he's coming toward you hold on
[Music]
sorry that's my fault
no you got it I mean let's still what do
you now I mean try shooting this London
I don't know that's the thing that's so
[ __ ] stupid is like I'm not learning
from my failures
alright it's a bad game but hold on let
give me the [ __ ] option
[Music]
like let me you're not gonna be able
jump across so run
let's just keep shooting him right now
shoot him - oh you know what
nice there you go okay um so all right
cool now what it's coming toward okay
okay so now I can jump across I bet
probably yeah okay right turn around you
[ __ ] he's come into our meat okay I
still can't jump across so good luck
try shooting him from there if you give
your rifle yeah he's trying to coming
I'm kind of shaky again it's not ah [ __ ]
I don't have any good weapons left all
right I still can't jump across just
keep trying to rifle it I am go back up
if you can
[Music]
I don't ok I'm shooting him a lot just
stay strong ok I'm out
please stock um maybe if I just get hot
now you can jump across try jump across
now hold on um I literally think it like
I don't I don't know why can't I jump
there I'm up we're obviously missing
something here right it's a really bad
boss fight um yeah just continue yeah
but are we just gonna like stumble our
way through it well what else you
suggest
I don't know cheating no hon you've done
it for every other resi it's not every
other exact it's not like it's above us
yeah it is right now it is I wasn't all
right hon I could I don't think it needs
this let oh you know I'm gonna bring my
rifle with me so then I can actually
help more on your side ok um I don't
never I don't lay low I'm gonna get rid
of my shotgun because I haven't been
able to shoot him from close up anyway
or maybe I'll give you asset rounds for
your grenade launcher - that'll be great
that would be very helpful you probably
don't need your machine oh I see why
everybody's just for more ammo
and I don't need my vest yeah I just
want to be able to shoot him from afar
I will here's like this isn't going well
what about my flash grenade here's this
I'll give you guys give us at rounds
cool what do you think on my flash
grenade should I use those try alright
I'm ready
do it
get everything I need I could bring
those because I think later on it
becomes dumb really ah this guy sucks so
we definitely need to so you know what
we do need to be hurting him yeah on
second thought maybe don't worry about
let's try this this time do what
don't worry about the boulder until he
jumps up to my area you know I mean um
what do you mean just don't worry about
the boulder yet just go over there and
like let's hurt him you so you'll need
to just slowly back up while I'm hurting
him that way while we're both hurt him
yet okay cuz I don't think that maybe
the polder doesn't matter until who
knows all right or maybe go down first
or did you try going yeah they really do
the same place like it's not like I'll
just circle around it then oh yeah okay
so since they both go to the same place
you could go up top you know I mean fall
and then loop right and then so I think
they keep showing us that red thing
because um that's the weak point so hear
me out on this one can you give me your
rifle round since I'm the first one
that's gonna be that make sense you want
my rounds I mean we're both gonna have
to shoot him eventually anyway I know
but I don't literally let's just try it
this way and then if this doesn't work
if comer since though yes I was cuz I'm
gonna be behind him first and I could
see the red thing you're not gonna be
behind him when he comes up to my side
let's just try this way mm-hmm um hey
I'll give you one anyway it's fine
okay
[Music]
run away
[Music]
nobody likes deer
yeah so I'll try starting this winnowing
[Music]
I'm tripping them up see just turn
around dodge so I don't get a lot of
time to like yeah it's just a one hit oh
god I got it I got it okay so I hit the
red thing uh-huh
so I think you just need to do the same
literally or try going for the boulder
or no she okay
we're figuring it out so okay so now he
goes to you but now what I don't assume
is I haven't even hit the boulder yet
right I would say go for what show me to
kill him try shooting him because you
gotta hit that red thing for sure I
think all right well I have to I'm not
even up there yet sorry what do you mean
up there I'm not with you okay so like I
don't think you can't get up there just
shoot him from there oh I see a good
ruler is what I'm saying okay look down
there I can't okay so now I can here we
go
[Music]
am I supposed to be shooting him in a
red part yeah there's a thing on his
back oh when it's back so maybe maybe
you do need a punchy builder now I don't
see what that difference that would make
Hey so now it's coming toward me oh my
god [ __ ] game I'm pushing the boulder
I could illiterate I couldn't go there
else
okay so I'm supposed to shoot him there
though his [ __ ] boss fight is so
[ __ ] stupid
hmm all right let's do it okay so yeah
it was easier than I thought beginning I
just need to shoot the resident I don't
think I'm able to see the red thing on
his back like you can that's yeah that's
why I was saying give me the rifle
rounds makes more sense right but you
can't do it later so then it doesn't
matter cuz you're just dying afterwards
is what I'm saying yeah no I get that
but I'm just saying like it might as
well give me to wrap around because I
can actually see it you're never going
you're you haven't yet at all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] no you know what what it doesn't
reveal itself until you're closest to it
what do you mean all right I figured it
out okay so you in order to open up the
red weak spot yes yeah see he has to be
like doing that thing like sign close so
did you do it
well I can't shoot it now okay so I
actually wait until yeah no it's only
when he's attacking oh that's so
dangerous because it's one-hit-kill yeah
but now we just need to figure out how
to do that for you yeah cuz like I might
just want to wipe right now well there's
no harm yet right I wasted a lot of ammo
oh we could try um like he's gonna come
up he's gonna almost kill me I'll jump
down okay he's doing right now
so I see it you see it yeah I just gotta
hit it
okay so do I push the boulder or do i
attack him that's yeah that's the
question I'd say go for the polder not
gonna come for me now I'll try to keep
him busy I just I haven't been able to
like do anything like I have a folder
try the folder and I push it and then
nothing happens I would say definitely
do the bold latest time push I'll slow
him down at least push push push push
llll Square Circle Square oh it's on
this arm now okay so you can't shoot it
you just need to hit the right spot is
it Lefton is it right arm or left arm
it's just left one so it's on the other
side his left arm okay so that's hard
for me to hit I'll do my best at lake
becomes like I'm supposed to jump across
here yeah like I feel very confident
that that's what I'm supposed to I see
it's I missed a stomach now oh all right
think let me I don't see it I saw it for
a second
maybe you do need to shoot him while
he's about to kill me remember what she
said oh you know what okay I'm gonna
hang off the edge just get ready to
shoot him are you reloaded I am reload
all right I'm going I only have six shot
you're ready right now okay see I mean
see is it exposed now huh
maybe I shouldn't look this up because
this is getting it on Emily please all
right
say something funny in the meantime all
right [ __ ] this is the worst of the
six it's a really bad boss fight I have
these flash bangs I wish I had magnum
rounds actually that would help I buy
them like what is the Magnum called
yeah that's W that one purchased um all
right so I don't I haven't been using
this so remove organize remove I'm not
[ __ ] around
bye
can i buy ammo or only guns wait a
minute so I think what so I'm I think I
just need to fall onto the edge did I
miss
no it's honestly like it's not that I
have to go the edge immediately and then
actually just pull myself up with the
square thing I guess I just didn't do it
long enough that's how a minuscule the
difference is between all right let's
just do it
it's a fun game all right right so I'm
not really sure what I'm supposed to do
then just run away right now yo you're
always still doing the thing where like
you hit him and get a second arm to it
so honestly when you go up to that
circular area and he starts swinging at
you you can jump down and flank him and
do it yourself but I'll help you out oh
so I'm supposed to do this on my own
I can help you but yeah I'm happy to do
it I just didn't know I just needed wait
I'll help you out regardless so when he
starts swinging his arm that's not
doesn't mean you're immediately gonna
get hit but yet just be careful with
your magnum rounds I guess I'm just
confused still he's literally when he
starts swinging is when but that's when
I like get one-shotted but yeah cuz
you're right on the edge you know I mean
all right
I'm here
all right hit it once you might be
coming up here now does he have ice
coming with you
[ __ ] I miss sorry um I can see it likes
all right I got it once I got it nice
oaky cool all right now just shoot him
to slow him down
no Boulder no not yet you want me to
shoot him to slow him down yeah he's got
to buy me time to have time to climb up
mm-hmm so just like I hear you don't use
Magnum dancer I'm doing my best
[Music]
wait okay so this is normal yeah hold on
okay I stopped him a couple times yeah
it's keeping her good nice this is my
last two well he threw a rock at me nice
he threw another Rock he's throwing up
I'm up alright now do the boulder
okay I'm going I think it's so dumb
I'm so do the boulder I'm doing my best
try it on school I have a thumb down
square square square square
LLL hook hook hook Circle Circle Circle
XXX Circle Circle Circle
xxx Ram nice all right so I think I jump
across now we just oh I think so that
makes sense I'll just come over there
and we'll shoot him alright come on over
growl at least we know what the [ __ ] to
do it he's dumb idiot yeah I can jump
across
oh so stupid ending care who wouldn't I
literally at the top square for a good
20 seconds shut up so we could be
[ __ ] it up again so run yeah up to
this edge I guess maybe that looks
important
who knows
just I guess now we just circle together
and [ __ ] him up in the back to get your
Magnum ready I'll try to but also stay
away from the edge and I mean gray or
just don't get hit fine I don't have
that much Magnum ammo go around behind
him it's fine we just literally fight
him normally now
all right swinging so try to shoot him
now if you can oh that thing when you
start swinging he's okay sorry
pardon
this will come out towards you should
start swinging um just try to learn out
I'm gonna go her about check what the
[ __ ]
thank God I guess so
alright try to get behind and just like
keep luring him you know I mean like
with the claw thing he's still going
always going for meat red shooting now
okay can I jump across here no I don't
know where his thing is do you see it no
maybe we have to do some damage
I guess just shoot him but now with the
Magnum I shot him over there maybe
there's something else dumb that we're
not doing
probably
I use [ __ ] maybe maybe we feel like
alarm toward this area and then [ __ ]
like God
oh [ __ ] he's coming up here I swing to
me now but there's no red thing so it
leads me to believe that where there is
some other like button prompt we're not
doing let's just we got a checkpoint
let's try to learn down here maybe
that'll do here yeah I don't know maybe
he like we dodged him and I know this
doesn't make sense but like we gotta
check my source we have some leeway now
wait seriously not gonna come down here
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what's going on
okay now we're in trouble
this is it
we might die but we got checkpoint don't
worry yeah okay whatever
there's no cliff there what's going on
all right all right do you have any idea
what to do kind of I don't know okay
hurry up
what do you want from me
yeah it should be on his back still not
sure maybe we just need to do more
damage
okay stay up here if you can ah yeah
maybe we just have the staff here Oh
perfect okay yeah we have a step here
and we could dodge it yeah it's on his
back okay we just we had to stay up here
that's it that's how stupid it is okay
okay why allow us to go to the other
spots
Oh hopefully
[Music]
yeah stay on opposite sides I got it
thanks um oh [ __ ]
so now I know it's gonna be on his chest
whoa it's so when he does this
apparently it's exposed on his chest
okay see it so it seemed in on it yeah
so damn nice Oh
that's what we're supposed to do okay
cool I guess so I just repeat the same
thing now it's on his back and then it's
gonna be on his chest
um he's going toward you yep sure is all
right I'll try to shoot okey my I'm
using machine I saw the best all right
sweet now the chest thing try to stay up
here I you know I had to battery right
you're right you should be able to see
it alright I'm sorry when he's done he's
done
I can't see I'll let you shoot
oh [ __ ] oh no that's alright to get it
yeah that just happens me I'll try I'll
learn for me it's just I'm in alright
okay thank God
and then it's on his back right yes ah
sorry my dad I'll shoot mature you did a
bad job luring he's coming
yeah alright alright [ __ ]
yeah it's no all right whatever we
doesn't do so when he raises it up you
shoot him on the back and then after
that's a world run shoot his chest got
it this is really dumb I'm just like
heartbroken this is like collage again
been such a it's been such an exhausting
process so far all right I have every
gun in the world just in case let's just
go with all gun
don't don't back up to the rim sorry
it's one that you get cornered alright
come on come up here quick just don't
get it by the whirlwind attack and don't
go down there
all right back or front for the chest
now chest no okay so that will be on his
right
[Music]
die you [ __ ] I hate you next time it's
on his chest
she's your Magnum my finishing sooner
okay
oh [ __ ] these shots up in alright sounds
back
um it's coming toward you I'll try to
shoot him I see it well good job God I
just [ __ ] him up when he turns around
this way
I only have one Magnum round all right
Biron Abel I've got a frat say hello see
should just be exposed
yeah [ __ ] I might have missed now you
got it
we got it
Oh God die alright then what the back
only takes one shot so we're fine on
that way you are the worst boss ever
trying to get a raise
don't go down the ramp you don't I'm not
I'm just circling the corner briskly I
gotta try to get over raising our pick
Toby doesn't swing yeah it's back right
yep sorry my bad for me too
it's exposure now got it sweet good job
all right chest just [ __ ] it up you got
it hey please don't die
let's plug it up
open up
talk about animals I got it I got all
these acid rounds next time should do it
oh my god I hope so
rely on you just shootings our lands
right for right now so I might even
decide all right the new dialog thing so
that's good you ready yeah all right I
got got it cool job coming nice but [ __ ]
them up from this way all right
I can't move much dissolve might as my
rifle turn around turn around turn
around turn around
[Music]
turn up
[Music]
oh my god are we doing it right yeah
we're hitting it it's donal mistake a
lot so why doesn't this game follow the
rules of 300 watch out he's following
you I don't have anything I should have
bought another weapon like you did
I tried shooter now be here
he's doing it faster so I think we're at
the last stage for sure good yes stay
there okay
I got it I don't have any ammo okay I
have three acid rounds I'll just come
toward you you have no ammo at all okay
actually even if it's a handgun no I
don't have anything I just had bad
practice anything is used
turn around you [ __ ] anything really at
this point but we're out of ammo I'll
learn him when he raised his hand you
came on the back get ready to dodge that
swing soon
nice huh yeah well go the opposite way
me sorry
oh [ __ ] on his back all right you going
right or left sorry I need to know
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] my mother looking I only have five
bullets is it actually a nightmare God
do it do it thank you you get you right
there you don't to see it perfectly
what
Oh
[Applause]
yeah wish I'd use you at any mo at all
all right give it turnarounds quick not
shoot it okay he's come toward me I got
it I have one in all you ever um get the
grenade line or shotgun out or anything
yeah shotguns gonna be better than that
machine gun just get close to a [ __ ]
waste okay you can go up right next him
right now
oh my god that was a bad boss fight his
shop I think that's the game
I hope wait okay just in case pick up
your controller this game is no one to
be stupid like that
fall in oh he's like [ __ ]
Frankenstein's monster floating out into
hey Mikey boy girl is not allowed to be
here it's my team Michaela I've never
been more happy to be done with a video
game
are we late did you guys meet and we
were here till bummer
to most native this is gonna be like a
tune-up our episode
oh yeah whatever move on to residents
and ultimate penultimate
that's a happy
oh my god that was the word no you got
your squares no I didn't press anything
why did ask us to no but it might
probably Mikey doing something
[Music]
yay
hey you Esther he just had two RPGs when
the helicopter and brothers for Mikey
one and two and three and four five was
for you Mikey
we beat it
how about after this we do some I know
this overtime I know this is
unprecedented but someone's been waiting
outside for me for a long time do you
mind if I run out and come back in for
the end of over it would be like five
seconds I promise the endings here isn't
it no like literally I have to go out
now I'm sorry it's unavoidable I'm sorry
people watching up here back I'll be
back for the ending no more I find we
ended this game the way we started it
with me doing it alone for a future
without fear yeah it's worth
his mouth was moving
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
No
well we beat it I hated that ending
although I was really glad to get to it
um damn repetitive uh boss fights
weren't fun and kind of hard to do I
think the best part of it is being able
to do it with a friend like having a
player number two is so great um but
definitely not like not really my cup of
tea but having another person around was
like the best part of that game but it's
done which is great because that means
that we get to move on to Resident Evil
6 next well on our way to Resident Evil
7 by 2018 which I'm excited about
it's kind of like waiting for the
release of a game and then it's like
sorry it's delayed um I hate this game
alright oh we're done wait we beat it
that's it wait our grades were oh right
let's get this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
wait overall I want it overall grade
though be sack
alright that's it I am wait okay yeah
overall thoughts on past evil 5 I told
them while you were gone
okay sweet I'm assuming you didn't like
ah is my least favorite of the six
really 543 yeah oh definitely um you
ready for rows equals six so the list
goes so one three make why is there like
bonus stuff good question I remember
yeah so okay six is like oh no sorry
your ranking so one two one four two
three five close to mine mine's one two
four
I might even like two more than four one
and two or like two is really good yeah
she's good I really want to remake I'm
sure we'll get announced sometime soon I
Capcom I thought it would be at e3
honestly but it wasn't I thought yeah
there was a lot but people were
expecting that I saw that I it's not a
great game I enjoyed playing it with you
I'm glad you got to play we're playing a
whole nother one it was almost the end
of our friendship but we held on oh it's
gonna be the end of our friendship well
imagine like resin well five annoying
things but without like the satisfying
hit detection if that makes sense like
in six I remember shooting people and
not really knowing whether I was hitting
them I remember six
I remember six being too long so if I
think that was really long
anyway that was resin evil five finished
for you guys don't forget to Like and
subscribe and we will see you guys for
episode one of Resident Evil 6 next week
will it be next week yeah yep most
likely thanks for sticking with us game
thought you know I wanted to [ __ ]
quit